[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans audition
publique deuxième mois de guerre en
ukraine est pour l'instant pas de porte
de sortie très clair l'armée russe
poursuit son oeuvre de destruction des
villes en faisant chaque jour des morts
sans que rien ni personne ne parvienne
pour l'instant arrêté poutine pas plus
europe d'ailleurs que quiconque bonsoir
jean michel bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous par michel vous êtes
président du conseil européen vous venez
de vous faire d'ailleurs réélire à
l'unanimité pour deux ans et demi je
crois vous êtes l'ancien premier
ministre belge avait 46 ans et vous
connaissez très bien l'ukraine vous
connaissez très bien le président céline
ce qui est vous avez maintes fois eu
l'occasion de rencontrer vladimir
poutine le fauteur de guerre donc ça va
être intéressant d'avoir votre analyse
évidemment sur ce dossier majeur où en
sommes nous exactement du conflit après
un mois et trois ou quatre jours de
guerre le président céline ce qui
précisément qui tend la main aux russes
que faut-il en penser quel est le bilan
des sanctions européennes quelle place
trouve l'europe dans le tête à tête qui
semble peut-être s'installer entre baden
et poutine tous les défis évidemment
face
face auxquels l'europe évidemment répond
depuis plus d'un mois on va en parler
avec président bush l'état mme tran me
yves thréard vous écoutent avec
attention et débriefera vos déclarations
et vincent roux vous posera une question
d'actualité dans quelques instants
d'abord je voudrais vous entendre
peut-être sur une information qui nous
est parvenu il ya une bonne heure
l'oligarque russe abramovitch c'est une
information qui n'est pour l'instant pas
confirmé à les livrer par le wall street
journal
abramovitch qu'on connaît bien pour être
le propriétaire du club de chelsea entre
autres auraient été empoisonnés début
mars est ce que c'est une information
qui vous semble vraisemblable moi je
peux pas confirmer cette information là
donc je vais être prudent dans mon
expression néanmoins la technique de
l'empoisonnement n'est pas une technique
nouvelle au départ de la rue si on dans
l'histoire on était confronté appelé
reprises à des tentatives wade acte
d'empoisonnement par ailleurs
abramovitch et et à un des oligarques
qui était identifiée au début de la
guerre comme étant une personnalité qui
peut être prouvé tenté de jouer un rôle
de médiation
je le crois parce que ton était
ukrainienne et je les comprends
avant la guerre avant le déclenchement
de la guerre mais également après le
déclenchement de la guerre ont tenté
d'utiliser toutes les personnalités dont
elle tente elle pensait qu'ils étaient
susceptibles de pouvoir jouer un rôle
pour tenter d'avoir des fils de
discussion c'est ainsi que pour ce qui
me concerne comme avec d'autres fait à
la demande du maire et les skis que
avant le déclenchement de la guerre et
après les enfants de la guerre nous
avons eu des contacts directs avec avec
venu à poutine et abramovitch qui a des
origines chrétiennes par an exactement
exactement et donc c'est peut-être une
des raisons pour laquelle ils auraient
pu servir dieu qui a qui ont amené le
ton était écrit n'a imaginé que son
positionnement
c'est à dire un positionnement dans dans
l'activité économique n'est en proximité
avec l'arrêté politiques à moscou
pouvait peut-être permettre de qu'il
puisse jouer un rôle en tout cas que ces
derniers jours sur saône et on n'a pas
vu des résultats tangibles de ce point
de vue là alors c'est la guerre donc les
choses sont assez complexes par
définition mais c'est vrai que il était
aussi sous le coup évidemment des
sanctions qui frappaient les zones
iggert et notamment les sanctions de
l'union européenne et du gouvernement
britannique donc une forme d'agents
doubles en tout cas voilà c'est une
information évidemment dans le contexte
qui pourrait prouver que veulent les dix
mille a dit mir poutine n'a renoncé à
aucune de ces méthodes joe biden samedi
dans un discours au château royal de
varsovie a appelé à changer de régime
même si la maison blanche ensuite tenté
d'atténuer la déclaration mais en
revanche il a assumé la sans problème
d'appeler poutine boucher est ce que ça
aide ce type d'expression à trouver la
voie de la négociation
c'est en tout cas ce sont pas des mots
que moi que moi j'utilise je pense que
des crimes de guerre sont commis et
c'était la justice internationale qu'il
appartiendra de décider quelles sont les
sanctions qu'ils soient une punition qui
sont nécessaires parce que je crois au
droit international quand on croit au
droit international on doit croire aussi
à la justice internationale
c'est certain c'est que ce n'est pas par
plaisir mais c'est par nécessité selon
nous selon les européens que l'on doit
maintenir un fil de discussion d'admir
poutine et bouble de sujets doivent être
discutés on voit les désastres
humanitaires pour le moment si on veut
faire progresser des possibles convoi
humanitaire sont faire progresser des
couloirs humanitaires
des contacts sont indispensables on voit
qu'il y à aussi négociations directes
qui a démarré entre les ukrainiens et
les russes et si nous voulons soutenir
les ukrainiens sur le plan politique on
doit aussi pouvoir maintenir ce fil de
discussion pour donner un certain nombre
d'arguments pour donner aussi un certain
nombre d'informations à la dînette
poutine parce que parfois on peut avoir
l'impression que vladimir poutine n'a
pas nécessairement l'ensemble des angles
de vue sur arize en situation moi il m'a
moins maussade le slam à cela m'a frappé
de constater ces derniers temps qu'ils
avaient l'impression d'un raid mais
putin de plus en plus isolé par rapport
à ce qui avait pu être son rôle sur le
plan international dans le passé et donc
il est important que nous puissions nous
comme européen pas seulement les
européens mais certainement les
européens avoir cette discussion qui
nous permet de le dire directement
comment nous voyons nous les choses lui
dire par exemple que nous voyons bien
que les calculs qu'il avait probablement
fait avant le déclenchement le
déclenchement de la guerre pour beaucoup
d'entre eux se sont révélés faux il
pensait probablement ébranlés l'ukraine
et peut-être même provoquer la
désintégration du gouvernement zns qui
en quelques heures après avoir envoyé
160 missiles sur l'ukraine ça ne s'est
pas passé il pensait probablement avoir
des européens très très bien pensé et un
défaut de renseignement
et il a été mal renseignés par ses
services sur la capacité de résistance
de l'ukraine par exemple moi je crois
qu'il y à surprendre je crois qu'il il y
à un cocktail probablement il est dans
son propre logiciel on pourra y revenir
certainement qui n'est pas le logiciel
l'union européenne et de nos partenaires
et de nos existe un premier élément
deuxième élément je crois effectivement
que le monde voit que l'armée russe n'a
probablement pas la puissance que l'on
pouvait imaginer pour ce que on voit que
là où beaucoup imaginent et ont quelques
jours
l'ukraine s'effondrerait on voit qu'il
ya au contraire une nation qui résistent
envoyer une armée qui résiste bien le
gouvernement extrêmement courageux qui
tient le pays droit dans un conte et
d'une brutalité inouïe juste je reviens
un mot sur la sémantique parce que c'est
vrai que les opinions publiques ne
comprennent pas toujours qu'on ne puisse
pas appeler un chat un chat par exemple
milosevic on l'appelait le le boucher de
belgrade il a été on le sait traduits
devant la justice pour crimes contre
l'humanité vous le disais ils enquêtent
sur des discriminations récriminations
qui serait semblable pour poutine tout
le monde le pense que c'est un boucher
d'onde tout le monde voit la façon dont
ils traitent les civils d'ukrainiens on
ne peut pas le dire moi je comprends que
tu te d'aucuns le dise je respecte plus
d'aucun pour s'exprimer ce point de vue
là simplement dans ma capacité aussi
président du conseil européen je suis
amené aelst travail pour faire en sorte
que l'on puisse cessez le feu le plus
vite possible à voir le déclenchement
d'un réel processus de paix dès que ce
sera possible pour l'instant voir bien
ça ne fonctionne pas mais ne faut pas
renoncer et je ne veux pas utilisé une
rhétorique qui conduit à donner des
excuses pour provoquer de l' escalade on
voit bien que le chemin difficile sur
lequel on se situe il est lié au
caractère de la russie qui est membre du
conseil de ses yeux des nations unies
mais qui détient l'armé nucléaire vous
pensez qu'il s'agit - il s'agit
d'essayer d'aller va désescalade et ni
par la rhétorique ni par les actes
provoqué en sont deux situations qui
serait encore plus dangereuse selon vos
informations les américains présidée par
un job hayden qui le traitent de
criminel de guerre de bush et de tueurs
ya même quelques mois ils ont un fils de
communication avec poutine on tient je
ne parle pas au nom des américains mais
ça vous dit de vous dire en tout cas une
chose est de certitude c'est que en fin
de semaine passée jeudi nous étions
rassemblés avec les partenaires de
l'otan les états unis le canada le
royaume uni et nous étions exactement et
nous sommes exactement sur la même ligne
est une ligne d'action très ferme à la
fois par du soutien massif à l'ukraine
dans différentes dimensions est à la
fois par la mise en place de sanctions
extrêmement sévère parce que nous
faisons la même analyse la situation
elle est sérieuse et les graves elle met
en péril pas seulement la sécurité de
l'europe elle met en péril architecture
sécuritaire du monde et est ce que c'est
une guerre de poutine l'autocrate contre
le principe même de la démocratie
et même l'occident
je le crois je crois d'abord
effectivement ce qui nous est important
que c'est la guerre vous l'avez dit la
dir de poutine je ne pense pas sur la
guerre du peuple russe et une différence
importante et je pense est une guerre
qui est déclenché pour un cocktail de
différentes raisons certainement il ya
une forme de nostalgie
impérial certainement il ya la volonté
peut-être d'aller à poutine de l'essai
de laisser un héritage ans il considère
être la zone d'influencé de la grande
russie je pense que là la vraie raison
la raison authentique je fais assez
convaincus de cette analyse c'est la
crainte la crainte panique de la
demi-heure poutine et des autocrates en
général face à la liberté face à la
démocratie moi j'ai parlé souvent à
gagner la routine j'ai pu constater
souvent combien il était obsédé par sa
version 2 6 s'était produit un hayden au
moment où un peuple libre maidana bien
fier pour à jeudi nous regardons
l'europe ne regardons le lien
transatlantique parce que nous voulons
une société de liberté une société
démocratique est ce que nous avons vu
parce que c'était la réalité comme un
peuple qui fait le choix de la liberté
la démocratie le choix souverain
peut être vu comme à papoter le problème
en vue comme un coma comme une forme de
coup d'état qui menaçait sa zone
d'influencé et puis vous le savez il y
as en ukraine des populations
russophones donc l'interaction de ces
différentes populations peut lui faire
redouter que le peuple russe tôt ou tard
voit qu'il ya un autre modèle de société
un autre modèle qui est de mener la
liberté alors joe biden a été très clair
justement est sans doute lorsque vous
l'avez rencontré l'a répété samedi à
varsovie pas question d'intervenir à
moins qu'un des pays alliés de l'otan ne
soit touchée par un missile une bombe
russe sur son territoire alors là
évidemment c'est l'article 5 ont
déclenché serait la réaction militaire
de l'otan
c'était important qu'ils le disent et qu
il le réaffirme de façon très ferme oui
c'est si oui pourquoi non c'est
important parce qu'on peut pas laisser
le moindre le moindre doute pas la
moindre ambiguïté c'était un message à
poutine pour qu'elle comprenne il ya
bien sûr ça veut dire que chaque
centimètre carré de l'espace aérien ou
ou terrestre de l'otan sera défendue bec
et ongles et toute la puissance à toute
la puissance de l'otan et en cela à voir
à bruxelles ce jeudi en même temps le
même jour la réunion de l'otan et la
réunion du conseil européen puisse la
réunion du g7 était un message d'unité
d'unités inaltérable et c'est un message
qui était nécessaire n'empêche enfin
pendant en attendant plutôt la formule
des manuels macron c'est qu'il faut
arrêter la guerre sans faire la guerre
et les opinions publiques voit aussi que
poutine est en train de détruire le cren
et que l'occident les alliés de l'otan
l'europe ne peuvent rien faire ne
peuvent rien empêché vous comprenez la
compréhension que ça peut susciter qu'on
laisse poutine je comprends détruire ab
européen comprend deux choses comprend
parfaitement la formule emmanuel macron
qui représente parfaitement cette unité
transatlantique et au delà de l'étudiant
transatlantique les pays amis les pays
partenaires qui soutiennent cette
démarche et donc ça on pourrait nous
devons mobiliser les instruments dont
nous disposons pour stopper vladimir
poutine en ukraine et éviter le risque
de la contagion de l'aggravation et
comment on peut faire ça on peut faire
ça il faut expliquer ça à nos citoyens
partout en europe on peut faire ça de
deux manières d'une part en soutenant
massivement des ukrainiens qui résiste
au moment où on se parle ils résistent
ils se battent pour leur liberté pour
leurs enfants pour leur terre il se bat
pour nos valeurs à nous également c'est
un premier problème au fait avec du
financement et on le fait c'est une
première dans l'histoire de l'union
européenne avec des armes pour la
première fois ça montre aussi le
tournant qui se produit sous nos yeux
sur le plan européen et puis un deuxième
élément ce sont les sanctions qui sont
très durs qui sont entrain tulu reuze
facilité de faire plus le régime à
moscou joe biden enfin l'a dit aussi ça
va durer des mois vous êtes sur cette
ligne on est parti pour une guerre qui
va durer des mois
difficile de prédire avec avec certitude
ce qui peut se passer mais il ya
effectivement un risque que ça prenne
que ça prenne du temps et c'est certain
que c'est ce qui se passe maintenant
aura des conséquences pendant de
nombreuses années un pacha touche
directement à ce qui était l'élément
fondamental après la deuxième guerre
mondiale où c'est le passé quand un
ordre multilatéral a été a été mis sur
place avec la loi internationale les
principes de souveraineté d'intégrité
territoriale qui ont été considérés
comme des principes au départ desquels
on allait organiser les relations
internationales alors encore une fois on
va en parler dans un instant avec
brigitte et etam tran huy mais un mot
quand même parce que la déclaration date
d'aujourd'hui olaf scholz le chant c'est
réellement infirmer que la demande reuze
d'un paiement en roubles de ses
livraisons d'énergie
montré que poutine est ce que vous êtes
sur cette ligne je le pense aussi et
c'est la démonstration que les sanctions
produisent leurs effets alors on savait
quand on a déclenché le premier paquet
de sanctions que il va falloir quelques
jours quelques semaines pour qu'elle
prenne leur plein amplitude et on voit
jour après jour que ces sanctions sont
donc plus en plus douloureuse au total
ces 900 individus de nombreux oligarques
parmi eux y compris tu admires poutine
salé lavrov qui sont visées par ces
sanctions c'est le coeur du système
financier et économique russe qui est
touchée avec le système bancaire avec la
banque centrale russe donc ça montre
aussi que probablement on apprit poutine
par surprise parce qu'ils ne
s'attendaient pas à cette capacité de
prendre des sanctions aussi dur aussi
rugueuse aussi impactante mais je
reconnais probablement nous sommes
surpris nous mêmes en découvrant la
capacité la puissance nous avions quand
l'union européenne avec nos partenaires
déclenché ce type de sanction on verra
tout à l'heure ainsi quand même le
paiement en europe ça va pas poser des
problèmes supplémentaires
aux pays qui sont fournies par la russie
je reviens juste un mot avant qu'on
retrouve vincent roux au figaro live
juste un mot sur le périmètre qu'à
dessiner très précisément belledonne
pour une intervention de l'otan charles
michel un missile qui tomberait un 20 km
de la frontière ukrainienne sur le sol
polonais est ce que les pays de l'otan
et gérer dès lors qu'il ya dès lors
qu'il ya une attaque
sur un centimètre carré de le temps le
temps réagir vous dis ça parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de scepticisme des ormes sinon
on dira c'est 20 km c'est pas très grave
je suis extrêmement ferme par rapport à
cela est extrêmement convaincu qu'il n'y
aura pas loin d'une citation c'est très
clair merci cher michel vincent roux
vous allez le voir apparaître ici du
figra buissière alive va vous poser une
question bonsoir chers vincent
bonsoir c'est à vous
pour son chant michel
puisqu'on parle d'ukraine
ya une question c'est l'adhésion la
demande de l'ukraine
d'adhérer à l'union européenne
on a compris que notamment un certain
nombre d'états particulièrement la
france et demi était pas favorable
dans un délai très rapide vous
personnellement quel est votre point de
vue sur la question donc moi je
comprends parfaitement cette demande
exprimée par le président ukrainien
j'aurais parlé très souvent avec lui
avant le déclenchement de la guerre et a
fortiori au moment où la demande a été
formulée c'est un premier point 2 les 27
chefs d'état et de gouvernement réunis à
versailles il y a trois semaines ont
donné un message très très chaleureux
très très fort l'ukraine c'est la
famille européenne y ait pas de doutes
par rapport à cela et c'est pas quelque
chose de banal de dire cela ce une
démarche qui est une démarche
d'affection qui montre ce lien de
solidarité oui si on éviterait et puis
troisième élément et puis troisième
élément on à enclencher immédiatement le
processus vous savez que habituellement
ils font recette et oui moi avant que
l'on enclenche le processus en demandant
à la commission de rendre un avis qui
démarre cette procédure il a fallu
quelques jours seulement pour que le
processus soit déclenchée c'est donc une
accélération qui montrent que l'on prend
en considération la cité la situation
exceptionnelle et puis un autre élément
que je mettrai en évidence parce que nos
citoyens doivent bien comprendre cela le
débat sur l'élargissement de manière
générale est un débat difficile pourquoi
parce que en europe on a besoin pour
vous deux sujets de l'unanimité pour
prendre des décisions au plus qu'on
élargit au plus le défi est complexe et
donc beaucoup disent à juste titre c'est
le cas en france et ailleurs on doit en
parallèle quand on progresse sur des
débats relatifs à un élargissement
possible voir comment on rend l'union
européenne plus agile plus rapide plus
flexible sa capacité de décider et de
protéger l'unité en même temps et vous
savez il ya d'autres pays qui ont
demandé aussi l'adhésion à l'union
européenne pour certains d'entre eux les
procédures ont démarré il ya quelques
années dans les balkans occidentaux
par exemple et vous savez aussi entre
temps la géorgie la moldavie ont
introduit des demandes ont ce sujet là
est un sujet que nous prenons
extrêmement au sérieux nous voulons
soutenir et je veux soutenir
personnellement je veux soutenir ce
choix libre souverain des ukrainiens de
se tourner vers les valeurs de l'union
européenne et puis il ya un dernier mot
que je vais indiquer ce que les
ukrainiens sont en train de faire c'est
nous démontrer en réalité quelle est la
puissance et la force et valeur parce il
se bat pour ses valeurs qui sont les
valeurs du projet européen passant quand
vous dites que vous voulez soutenir une
réponse rap et de jean-michel une
réponse rapide quel est le sens quelle
est concrètement comment se manifeste ce
soutien est ce que vous voulez qu'on
aille vers l'accélération comme le veut
le veulent plusieurs pays d'europe
centrale ou bien c'est juste un soutien
moral comme l'expriment emmanuel macron
par exemple comme je voulais un dj et
déjà il ya déjà une forme d'
accélération par rapport à la pratique
habituelle et puis c'est moi dans ma
capacité devant un concert au tas qui a
distillé décidé immédiatement de porter
ce débat au conseil européen dans les
jours qui ont suivi cette demande en ce
sens en terre ce sont des actes je veux
évidemment respecter la décision d'une
reprise par les institutions parce que
je suis je respecte l'état de droit
européen mais vous comprenez vous
comprenez que je pense que non on ne
peut pas fermer les yeux par rapport à
ce débat on peut pas baisser la tête on
devra avoir ce débat mais je veux mais
ce débat dans la rationalité serviette
il faudra aussi être capable de
progresser et de se mettre en ordre pour
faire en sorte que l'on puisse se garde
une capacité effective de décision et
que des élargissements additionnel
n'amène pas à paralyser le projet
européen alors que c'est exactement
l'inversé que nous souhaitons et celle
avec nous démontrons on montre que l'on
peut agir et décider merci beaucoup
vincent merci à vous en direct du figaro
live vous présente brigitte boucher pour
ces faits et à mme tran huy pour public
sénat qui vont approfondir les questions
sur l'europe face à la guerre bonsoir
chers michel alors de nouveaux
pourparlers sont en cours entre
l'ukraine et la russie le président
heynckes qui étudie la demande russe
d'une neutralité de l'ukraine est ce que
c'est une idée que vous approuvez en
tout cas c'est pas moi d'approuver cette
idée là si on est conséquent et je veux
conséquent c'est bien le peuple
ukrainien entre de ses dirigeants
souverain qui doit décider ce qui est
acceptable et ce n'est pas acceptable
dans ces négociations une on est là pour
soutenir politiquement pour pour aider
pour pour appuyer c'est un premier
élément et c'est vrai je vais parler
souvent le président ukrainien il est
ouvert à regarder ce que pour était sur
l'appel des garanties de sécurité de
part et d'autre s'agit pas simplement
pour l'ukraine de données garantie à la
russie c'était d'ailleurs ses traders
fort puisque c'est plutôt la russie qui
manière très brutale et sauvage a montré
la manade justement ce serait quoi cette
neutralité de l'ukraine ce sera un
modèle à l'autrichienne à la suédoise à
quoi ça ressemble à un si petit ce qui
est certain c'est qu'elle panzani s'ils
comptent sur un certain nombre de pays
partenaires de pays amis pour apporter
des garanties de sécurité ce qui est
certain aussi sur l'a7 débat là et c'est
le conseil que nous voulons donner aux
ukrainiens qu'ils négocient c'est de
veiller à ce qu'il y ait un regard sur
l'ensemble de la région donne un exemple
le bélarus qui est devenu réalité 1 et à
vassaliser par moscou le bélarus a
décidé les peu de temps de changer sa
constitution pour permettre le
déploiement d'armes nucléaires ça n'est
pas banal ça veut donc dire que ce sujet
tout aussi être abordée et ça monte à
côté des pourparlers directs entre
l'ukraine et la russie pour paris qui
sont indispensables parce que je le
répète c'est l'ukraine qui doit
déterminer ce qui est acceptable et ce
qui ne l'est pas en terme de
souveraineté l'union européenne à sa
place naturellement et doit occuper sa
place naturellement parce c'est la
sécurité de l'europe et au delà le prof
du souci du monde qui est en jeu et nous
sommes autour de la table pourquoi mais
parce que c'est plusieurs états
européens qui sont susceptibles d'être
sollicités pour octroyer des garanties
de sécurité nous sommes autour de la
table par les sanctions que l'on a
décidé mais fait de nous un acteur afin
de tenter de stopper cette guerre le
plus vite possible alors au sommet
européen dernier sommet européen il ya
une évacuation humanitaire de mario paul
qui a été décidée il ya encore 150 mille
civils sur place et il a été dit que la
turquie est là res j'aurai un rôle quel
rôle exactement jouerait ces deux pays
de manière plus générale au delà de la
grèce et la turquie sont ses vrais très
très impliqué france on ressent bien
qu'il y à beaucoup d'initiatives qui
sont prises qui ont d'ailleurs canaliser
notamment par les organisations
internationales comme la croix rouge
afin de rendre possible des évacuations
de civils afin de rendre
possible il ya des as tu joues si l'on
était possible oui au début alors très
très beau l'axé de tête
c'est même pire que star est pour vous
dire le cynisme auxquels nous sommes
confrontés dans les premiers jours qui
ont suivi la grève lalanne la la la
guerre nous avons eu un contact direct
avec avec la demi-heure poutine parce
qu'un des sujets c'était le vivant il
voulait permettre d évaluation de civils
ukrainien vers la russie vous imaginez
la russie ce type de discussions très
concrètes que nous menons pour tenter
effectivement d'ouvrir démêlant peuvent
faire confiance à vladimir poutine pour
the suburbs cessez le feu le temps d'un
certain que jusqu'à maintenant on a vu
souvent que la confiance n'était pas
n'était pas au rendez-vous et que et que
les promesses étaient faites n'étaient
pas respectées c'est la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes aujourd'hui ça ne
nous plaît pas nous détestons cette
situation mais nous devons effectivement
en utilisant les nations unies en
utilisant la croix-rouge d'en mettre
ensemble en contact direct les
ukrainiens les russes pour tenter de
résoudre ces sujets qui sont absolument
dramatiques et i et qui font froid dans
le dos nous voyons toutes et tous des
images sont absolus mais la solution
elle vient du dialogue entre les
ukrainiens et russes mais je pense que
c'est au delà au delà de ce dialogue
direct on voit bien que des tiers ont un
rôle à jouer c'est ce que nous faisons
quand nous sommes comptables président
matheron chancelier sol moi même avec le
présent poutine cédant seulement faire
de mobiliser la grèce et la turquie ces
deux intermédiaires vous semble
appropriez peut-être davantage pour
obtenir une adhésion note-t-il une
opération qui est indispensable c'est en
réalité il y ait la grèce qui la turquie
sont impliqués il ya beaucoup d'autres
pays qui sont impliqués pour essayer de
permettre qu'il y ait de la désescalade
et des solutions sur le terrain
humanitaire la grèce et la turquie sont
tous les deux membres de l'otan ce sont
des pays ça n'est pas un secret vous le
savez en france qui ont tenu des
tensions de manière régulière qui en
connaissent encore
également mais ce qui est essentiel en
tout cas c'est que au delà des tensions
qui ont été connus c'est que nous
aimions le plus possible de pays à
partager la même détermination à être
engagés à la fois pour cessez le feu
d'une part et à la fois pour tenter
d'apporter un petit peu d'espoir
humanitaire
3,8 millions d'ukrainiens ont déjà fui
le pays il ya des projections qui parle
même de 8 millions à terme quelle doit
être la répartition entre les pays de
l'union européenne et pour l'instant ce
qui moi me réjouis et c'est plutôt une
surprise c'est là aussi une surprise en
réalité c'est que spontanément il ya eu
un réflexe partout on n'aura pas suivant
partout en europe sans exception
d'accueil dans la dignité des soldats
d'acteurs la dignité et la solidarité
des réfugiés ukrainien on l'a même vu au
niveau municipal au niveau local ça
dépasse même les quarts des
gouvernements c'est plutôt quelque chose
qui est réjouissant qui montre aussi où
le coeur européen bas de quelques t il
et bacchantes est confronté à ce type de
situation in organisation qui bien sûr
et c'est pour ça que les chefs d'état
ont mandaté la commission européenne à
la fois pour soutenir plus fortement
ceux qui en ont besoin les pays qui sont
en première ligne naturellement et il
faut dire la vérité certainement les
premiers réfugiés ceux qui sont arrivés
dans les premiers jours de la guerre
sont ceux qui avaient des connexions
déjà familiales amicales avec des pays
européens ils avaient de la famille des
amis apprécient d'être certainement
certainement donc certainement cette
situation sera de plus en plus difficile
à gérer d'où l'importance vous avez
raison d'être organisée et de faire en
sorte que l'on puisse donner un cadre le
plus le plus cheap
européenne sont d'accord entre eux sur
une rémission venir
8 millions savez c'est pour ça que vous
posez la question c'est bien on nous
l'imposé de traditionnellement la
question migratoire est une question qui
est difficile et us is it toutes les
controverses les plus passionnés et vous
savez que jusqu'à maintenant on n'a pas
été capable d'imposer des quotas oubliée
et seal avec les enseignants
c'est certain en tout cas c'est qu'il ya
un élément sécurité sur le continent
européen
ce sont des pays européens qui sont les
premiers pays quand on traverse la
frontière pour fuir les bombes c'est sur
le sol l'union européenne pour ce pur se
situe donc ces éléments a certainement
contribuer effectivement à se réfléchit
plutôt un réflexe qui moi me fait me
fait plaisir c'est de solidarité est ce
qu'il ya une enveloppe prévue par
l'union européenne pour accueillir ces
réfugiés si oui de quel montant comment
elle serait pas retenu pour l'instant
nous avons des dg des premiers montants
dans ce rappel leur jeu peut être aux
techniques d'antan son appel les fonds
de cohésion pour être très rapide on
permet aux états membres le pouvoir rpt
est à louer rapidement des fonds qui
étaient déjà dédicacer ce serait il pas
suffisant on y dort sur le débat qu'on a
eue la semaine passée à bruxelles c'est
comment peut-on veiller ainsi de
l'argent additionnel pour les pays qui
vont en avoir besoin
je viens vous dire
bonjour mais supplémentaires par an il
ya donc il y avait les budgets européens
c'est une bonne chose au budget
pluriannuel et où ça nous donne une
capacité d'utiliser les moyens de faire
pour la flexibilité nécessaire on sait
qu'il ya eu des problèmes de
discrimination pour franchir les
frontières notamment on a vu ces images
d'étudiants africains refoulé
d'étudiants asiatiques qui montrent en
tout cas de personnes qui n'étaient pas
eu craignent n est ce que c'est encore
le cas aujourd'hui est-ce que vous avez
des informations
j'ai vu effectivement les informations
liées à des as des as des incidents et
chacun si tant est grave et doit être
dénoncé ce sont pas les valeurs
européennes nous sommes pas ça nous
sommes nous sommes fermes pour lutter
contre toutes les discriminations mais
j'ai rencontré très directement les
autorités polonaises elle tente et
l'ukrainienne ont été très fermes et
très clairs il n'y a aucune décision
prise par le gouvernement polonais ont
lourdement ukrainien de discriminer au
contraire les doigts des polonaises ont
permis que des milliers d'étudiants
africains arrivant en pologne puisse
être en mesure de rentrer chez eux oui
l'union européenne a créé un fonds
spécial doté de 500 millions d'euros
pour fournir des armes à l'ukraine les
états unis consacrent un million quatre
est ce que il suffisamment 1 milliard 4s
comprend suffisamment notre part est-ce
que c'est suffisant pour l'union et le
ça me permet de vous dire que c'est pas
500 millions que c'est bien un milliard
d'euros qui ont été mobilisés par
l'union européenne en deux tranches la
première tranche le troisième jour c'est
pour elle parle de 500 millions mais
depuis lors on ajouter 500 millions
supplémentaires puis surtout cela vient
en aide dition des moyens des états
manquent on peut pas chiffrer exactement
parce que tout n'est pas public pourrait
bien laisser jal est abondant fait se
font que c'était d'abord c'est important
de souligner que c'est une première pour
pour l'europe l'europe à première fois a
décidé de
mettre à disposition son frère d armes
un milliard d'euros c'est un fonds
intergouvernementales avec des armes et
tout ça s'est passé ces trois jours
après le début de la guerre le numéro
d'une fille m'a appelée stars samedi
matin tôt en me disant on a besoin
d'armes le plus rapidement possible on a
pris contact avec tous les états membres
à ce qu'on pouvait activer ces fameux
fonds qui étaient disponibles mais pas
utilisés et en quelques heures on a
réussi à activer et le week end les
premières livraisons pouvait intervenir
et ça vient c'est montant de 1 milliard
au total en met dix sion à risque
beaucoup d'états membres ce que beaucoup
d'états membres font en train de
donation
et
quel matériel vous fournissez on n'a pas
l'intention des détails par rapport à
cela c'est du matériel
militaire défensif alors je les fais
experts le soin de décrire ce qui est du
métal militaire défensif mais en clair
c'est de son décès du matériel qui
permet à l'ukraine de résister le
président ukrainien a demandé une aide
sans restriction est ce que c'est acquis
de la part des européens et est ce que
ça fait consensus mais c'est certain si
sans restriction ça veut dire son appel
en mauvais français pardonnez-moi la no
fly zone c'est à dire le contrôle de
l'espace aérien cet impact le temps n'a
pas souhaité faire considérant que si il
y avait une confrontation même sur le
plan aérien entre les armées de l'otan
et l'armée russe alors on prenait le
risque très sérieux de déclencher la
troisième guerre mondiale si tu ne
voulons pas donc je l'aïe avait un
consensus là dessus pour ne pas fournir
d'avion l ukraine donc je distinct de la
fourniture de matériels de pièces de
matériel d'une part et l'idée d'engager
des avions de combat c'est de ça dont on
parle alors d protection des boucliers
des boucliers aérien au départ du
territoire de l'otan et
si je devais le sabre je ne vous
répondrai pas parce que je présentais
je pense sur ces sujets là on doit être
intelligent et donc il n'est pas
question pour nous de montrer de la
manière dont nous essayons de soutenir
autant qu'il est possible l'ukraine sans
pour autant devenir co belligérants
parce quand on devient co belligérants
et citoyens partout comprennent bien
qu'il ya un risque de déclencher une
troisième guerre mondiale a des
conséquences à ce que ça représenterait
mais joe biden d'ailleurs craint une
attaque à l'armé chimique voir à l'armé
nucléaire ça vous paraît crédible et
c'est en tout cas extrêmement grave et
sa mort le soldat situation ce sont les
menaces voilées parfois et parfois
explicite qui ont été faites par les
autorités russes en termes d'armes
nucléaires ou les sous-entendus liés aux
armes chimiques et donc il est certain
que cet acte là serait un acte d'une
gravité absolue mais très au sérieux
nous prenons je pense que nous devons
tous prendre extrêmement au sérieux
parce que on vous voit bien que ce qui
se passe et le déclenchement de nous
dire qui tu ne diras massive et pardon
juste on a été traumatisée entre
guillemets avec des conséquences qu'on
voit aujourd'hui par la décision d'obama
de ne pas intervenir en syrie après l'
usage des armes chimiques ce scénario ne
se reproduira pas
peux pas parler au nom de l'otan je peux
vous dire ma conviction je pense
effectivement que si à un moment donné
des lignes rouges se sont exprimés si on
veut être crédible il faut qu'il y ait
des conséquences si ces lignes rouges
ont franchi en tout cas cette gare en
ukraine montre l'importance qu'il ya à
mettre en place une véritable europe de
la défense hasard du calendrier l'union
européenne vient d'adopter sa boussole
stratégique un ses priorités pour la
défense pour les dix prochaines années
comment renforcer les capacités de
défense européenne est ce qu on a déjà
un vrai calendrier mais des liens
paradoxe en réalité c'est lors de la
défense on en parle depuis très très
longtemps mais sans heurt des résultats
suffisamment tangible et le paradoxe
probablement c'est que parmi les
résultats qui n'étaient pas souhaitées
par de la demi-heure poutine il vient
d'aider en réalité les européens par ses
actes à comprendre que l'heure de la
défense était maintenant et qu'il
fallait pas tergiversé qu'il fallait
agir le trail avait démarré depuis
quelques temps puisqu'on avait préparé
cette boussole se rate et qui maintenant
a été validé et c'est très concret très
opérationnel dès cette année et dans les
prochaines années on va mettre en place
des marchés groupés en termes militaires
ce qui est une opération très concrètes
pour faciliter les rapprochements on va
mettre en place des coopérations en
matière industrielle en matière spatiale
en matière cyber on va mettre des forces
de réaction rapide sur pie européenne
c'est donc dire que évidemment le temps
est un pays extrêmement important pour
la sécurité centrale et que nous voulons
à l'inter de l'otan renforcer les
capacités d'action d'un terrain de
l'otan comment ça va s'articuler cette
europe de la défense avec l'otan mais on
le voit par exemple sur le plan de
sédières en ukraine ce qui est assez
frappant c'est que c'est l'union
européenne qui a coordonné
la livraison de matériel militaire
c'était quelque chose qui était
absolument inimaginable il ya quelques
mois encore ce n'est pas le temps qui
s'est occupé de cela pour les raisons
que l'on comprend pris sur le temps
pouvait pas être impliqués dans ce
conflit et nous avons une déclaration
pour rappel une opération conjointe
union européenne otan et d'ailleurs on
va devoir la renouveler j'espère
rapidement afin de bien organiser la
division la division
des responsabilités la division du
travail la parfaite synchronisation dans
le cadre de l'otan est-ce qu'il faut
qu'il y ait une armée européenne
qui soit mise en place et de combien
d'hommes moi je comprends qu'on puisse
se projeter dans d'antan pour certains
en tout cas dans l'idéal d'une armée
européenne je pense que si on veut être
réaliste et c'est mon cas et pragmatique
il faut des capacités de défense
l'armée européenne va ouvrir un débat
quand on envoie des hommes sur un
théâtre d'opérations il faut une
légitimité qui pour l'heure sont
légitimes et une légitimité nationale ce
sont les parlements qui ont la
responsabilité de manière directe ou
indirecte de valider les décisions que
les que les chefs d'état est vraiment en
prennent côté nous irons davantage
progressivement vers un engagement
politique européenne sur ce sujet là
mais si on veut être réaliste plutôt que
avoir ce débat qui sera un débat très
difficile l'armée européenne et
mitraillettes une journée retenant je
dis pas
que je ne crois pas je pense que le que
quelques le pas en avant que l'on
réalise pour l'instant est absolument
gigantesque et vouloir maintenant dire
les amis ce serait mieux une armée
européenne c'est la garantie de la
paralysie là on est en train de
progresser de façon spectaculaire pour
les défenses une défense européenne
davantage question
oui c'est ça vous ne disiez qu'il va y
avoir des achats groupés des achats
communs d'armements par exemple si je
prends un exemple les experts militaires
peut le détruire mieux que moi il y a
sur le plan européen autour de 105 en
systèmes d'armement différents quant aux
états unis il y en a entre une
quarantaine et une cinquantaine s'ils
feront un autre exemple la question des
munitions qui est importante en en
ukraine pour le moment chaque état
actuellement fait ses propres marchés
publics en termes de munitions alors
c'est un secteur où il ya pas mal de
standardisation d'ores et déjà on
pourrait en savoir plus et encourager
une coordination qui permettrait des
économies d'échelle il permettrait
davantage de rationalité et qui
permettrait d'aller de façon concrète
vers cette europe de la diva servir
l'industrie américaine c'est pour ça que
je parlais de coopération industrielle
ce n'est pas par distraction et il ya un
élément qui peut être est passée
relativement inaperçue j'espère j'espère
pas trop il ya tout de même vu ce fameux
week end ondéron pris cette décision
trois jours après le déclenchement de la
guerre
de livrer des armes au départ de l'union
européenne il ya une décision importante
prise par un état européen qui est
l'allemagne et qui a rompu avec sa
doctrine habituelles en matière
militaire en décidant de réinvestir dans
les prochaines années structurellement
massivement sur le plan militaire mais
c'est vrai que attendre au delà de cela
au delà de cela il y à une industrie
européenne la défense qui existent et
qui devra être encouragée le conforter
alors au cours du sommet européen qui
s'est tenu la semaine dernière il a été
décidé l'achat en commun de gaz ou
allez-vous un provisionné l'union
européenne il faut expliquer les choses
très très simplement nous sommes
dépendants en moyenne à 45 % de la
russie pour la livraison du gaz en
europe certains pays sont beaucoup plus
dépendant que d'autres certains ce soit
en dépendent oui mais par exemple aussi
des pays des pays qui sont faibles il
que nos villes plus faible que l'ags
michael uniquement la bulgarie par
exemple céder 80% de dépendance vous
imaginez ça fait quand même comme comme
un pack on agit extrêmement rapidement
et je suis très convaincu que dès le
prochain hiver on sera nettement moins
dépendants du gaz russe alors il ya deux
sujets c'est le gars qui vient via les
'pipeline' et là effectivement la russie
ne peut pas aisément détournés vers
d'autres acheteurs peut-être la chine
c'est un des sujets importants pour être
intéressé à acheter du gaz russe et puis
elle ce fameux gaz liquéfié qui peut
venir des états unis qui peut venir
aussi aux jeunes qu'ils peuvent venir
exactement qui peut venir exactement
petit peu dit aussi de pays du golfe le
qatar enfin d'autres d'autres et donc
nous sommes engagés depuis hier depuis
pas mal de temps déjà voir comment on
peut diversifier notre approvisionnement
en fortune où on est le plus vite
possible
cette capacité de celui
coûter moins cher parce que ce sont des
achats en commun ou est ce que ça a
coûté plus cher d'acheter du gaz naturel
liquéfié aux états unis parce qu'il va
falloir le transformer après c'est une
question centrale il faut dire la vérité
effectivement il y à il ya un risque
d'impact sur les prix que l'on voit
d'ores et déjà maintenant les citoyens
les entreprises le voit d'ores et déjà
maintenant l'impact avait démarré avant
la guerre ça s'est aggravé depuis la
guerre et dont les chefs d'état de
gouvernement ont mandaté la commission
européenne en extrême urgence à la fois
pour travailler
des achats groupés de gaz afin d'avoir
un impact à la baisse sur les prix de
travailler sur la diversification et
travaille sur nos infrastructures
également on a besoin en europe d'un
réseau d'électricité davantage
interconnectés pour avoir une capacité
plus forte en europe et de pouvoir gérer
ce sujet important énergétique on a
besoin aussi de terminaux pour ce gaz
liquéfié et d'avoir cette architecture
ce sujet là mais ça veut dire que vous
il faut intégrer le fait que ça serait
que ça montre à
ces jeux je veux être extrêmement
prudents certains experts nous
expliquait il ya quelques mois que la
hausse des prix du gaz était une hausse
circonstancielle on voit bien qu'ils se
sont se sont trompés donc moi je suis
beaucoup plus modeste certains experts
je ne fais pas de pronostic ce que je
crois par contre c'est que cette
question énergétique n'est pas seulement
une question de pouvoir d'achat une
question de rester social pour les
familles c'est ça bien sûr et il faut
être au rendez-vous de la protection
sociale pour les familles qui vont être
touchés c'est aussi
les deux les deux d'ailleurs c'est pour
ça que l'union européenne a
mis à disposition s'appelle la boîte à
outils c'était des suggestions de
mesures qui peuvent être prises sur le
plan national pour tenter de protéger au
maximum les citoyens et puis la question
géopolitique et on ne le découvre pas on
ne doit pas aujourd'hui que l'énergie
est liée à la question géopolitique
alors il y avait la question des
sanctions vous évoquez tout à l'heure il
ya la question de l'embargo qui a été
posée est ce que tous les pays étaient
d'accord autour de la table pour qu'il
n'y ait pas d'embargo vis-à-vis des
hydrocarbures russes mais bon il ya des
sanctions très dures qui ont été pris
sur des secteurs on parle peut-être pas
beaucoup parce ça a été décidé mais sur
le secteur de la cise sur le secteur du
fer c'est un impact très très très lourd
pour la russie avec des effets
collatéraux pour nous un premier élément
est analysé le regard dur ça aurait
quand même une très grande force vous
avez raison mais vous je pense que nous
avons le devoir d'être intelligent et
les sanctions ont été décidées ont été
construites ont été conçus pour faire
mal à la russie pas pour nous faire mal
à nous mêmes et certainement pas tant
qu'on n'a pas progressé et il faut le
faire rapidement en dans la
diversification de l'approvisionnement
et c'est pour ça que les européens sont
prêts à prendre des mesures
additionnelles quand ce sera nécessaire
une voulons aussi prendre des mesures
qui font mal au régime au kremlin pas
des deux hugo et trancher là pour la non
je sais pas si je vous dis parce que
nous sommes en train de progresser
rapidement sur la diversité sont
approvisionnées alors justement parce
que à quelle échéance on pourrait être
indépendant vis-à-vis moi je brille trop
lorsque dès le prochain hiver on aura
créé des progrès substantiels et le
prochain hiver vous allez voir que les
progrès seront extrêmement important
mais sa passion pour la totale
dépendance est ce qu'elle peut arriver
avant de nous certains certains pensent
et moi je suis plutôt de cela que si on
n'investit immédiatement comme on l'a
décidé on peut réussir autour de
l'horizon 2020 7 à sortir totalement de
la dépendance mais sortir déjà
massivement la dépendance change
complètement la donne change
complètement les équilibres il faut
aussi craindre une crise alimentaire
mondiale avec la guerre en ukraine avec
la pénurie de blé notamment que ça va
occasionner c'est ce que a dit emmanuel
macron la semaine dernière le programme
qui a été mise en place par les pays
européens le programme farm il est
inspiré du programme kovacs le programme
sur les vaccins pour les distribuer
voilà au pays les plus pauvres quand on
voit les énormes inégalités de
vaccination qui ont perduré dans le
monde est-ce que et ben c'est pas un
petit problème c'est donc un indice pour
ça parce que même si kovacs n'a pas été
un programme parfait c'est un problème
quand même qui a permis de faire en
sorte qu'il y ait des vaccins lui on
n'aurait pas eu du tout si elle sera
corrigée qui ferment d'un premier
élément 2e 2e et 2e éléments vous avez
raison on parle beaucoup pour l'instant
de l'énergie à juste titre mais il ya
une autre crise qui peut apparaître très
rapidement c'est l'actrice liés à la
sécurité alimentaire d'une pac d'une
part à l'impact sur les prix en europe
qui est qui sera probablement une
réalité et on a tenté d'agir c'est ce
que nous faisons aussi pour tenter de
maîtriser aussi cet impact et puis un
autre élément et c'est en cela que le
prêt en nacre on a bien fait de propos
cette initiative qui était accepté par
les vingt-sept à bruxelles la semaine
passée
c'est être engagée spécialement avec
l'afrique parce que à tant de pays
africains vont être confrontées à des
pénuries avec des risques majeurs ni
l'egypte par exemple qui déplaît 80 pour
se dire devant les landes qui dépend des
importations et d'autres pays également
et donc le pr le plan proposé par le
président de macron est important parce
que c'est une batterie de mesures
concrètes y touche aurait le commercial
qui touche un certain nombre de règles
liées aux importations et aux
exportations et à du soutien financier
également pour venir en soutien et on
sait que le continent africain fait face
à une démographie que l'on connaît avec
des conflits donc beaucoup de pays avec
de l'insécurité donc on sait que si à
cela s'ajoute une crise alimentaire il
est certain que cela va me delettrez
additionnel c'est pas une pression
migratoire additionnel également vers
l'europe tard également parlé des
sanctions il ya eu plusieurs sanctions
qui ont été mises en place à l'égard de
la russie est ce que vous les jugez
aujourd'hui efficace elles sont
efficaces elles sont intactes en dehors
bien sûr elles n'ont pas encore conduit
à stopper la guerre et ça et ça nous
savions quand on déclenche et les
sanctions ne savait pas être comme une
baguette magique la guerre qui s'arrête
dans dans l'instant à calais lorsqu'elle
s'en fit est alors pour vous aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qu'elle permette de lll et
vous voulez voter à juste titre quand le
chancelier ch lens il également dit on
voit que le régime est acculé s'il en
vient à demander que l'on paye les
factures des factures de gaz en roubles
donc on voit bien qu'il ya 102
d'éléments en russie qui montre que le
régime est sous pression quelques
exemples des rationnements des produits
alimentaires ont été d'ores et déjà
décidé autre exemple la pression massive
sur la liberté de la presse qui était
déjà extrêmement opprimés en russie qui
l'est davantage encore alors on voit
qu'il ya une pression qui est très très
forte sur le régime et nous savons ce
que les sanctions vont continuer dans
les jours les semaines qui viennent
en augmentant justement les sanctions
nous nous avons pris des décisions et je
leur dis que je ne peux que le rappeler
qui vise à faire mal aux régimes pas à
nous rendre plus fragiles vont rester
solide effort parce si nous sommes
faibles et nous menions n'aura plus la
possible dès demain de maintenir et
d'activer le cas échant des pressions
supplémentaires autre ère de sanctions
additionnelles est ce que vous estimez
aux dernières questions et réponses
rapides et toutes les entreprises
européennes devraient quitter la russie
moi je demande aux entreprises
européennes de respecter l'état de droit
européen et les règles ont été décidées
cette soirée ce sont les sanctions ont
été décidées je vois bien les débats qui
peuvent avoir lieu c'est le cas en
france d'ailleurs sur elle son savoir si
des entreprises doivent-elles et au delà
des sanctions qui ont été décidées et je
n'ai pas l'impression j'étais pas
l'intention pardon de m'exprimer à la
place des entreprises dont c'est la
responsabilité de mesurer chaque fois la
balance entre d'une part j'imagine la
pression la pression peut-être monsieur
bako gens par exemple
pas l'intention de dire des choses
la rhétorique par rapport à par rapport
à ceux là je les chacun apprécie et mais
je vous vois bien aussi le dilemme qui
peut être posée par ce que je vois bien
aussi qu'il ya des activités économiques
qui représentent une valeur financière
et je vois bien aussi qu'il ya
certainement des tentations
d'expropriation des nationalisations
sont aussi des réalités après que la
réponse la réponse simple et difficile
sur ce sujet merci beaucoup brigitte
boucher et amstrad mais on va accueillir
yves frère quand même pas pousser cette
question l'enjeu est beaucoup le disent
des élus d'aidé européen c'est que on
finance la guerre de poutine à travers
sa le maintien de certaines activités
c'est comme ça que yannick jadot par
exemple candidat écolo la présidence de
la république en france a été jusqu'à
dénoncer une complicité de crimes de
guerre par l'entreprise total vous allez
me dire je ne veux pas me prononcer mais
quand même cette idée qu'on finance
poutine vous pouvez configurer c'est
insupportable certains c'est certain
c'est que et je le dis encore une fois
l'europe et dépendants du gaz russe et
c'est certain vous êtes les sanctions
sont sans précédent il était
inimaginable il y a quelques semaines
encore et sont des sanctions qui ont un
but il vise à stopper cette cash machine
qui alimente la guerre au départ du
kremlin on n'arrive pas en une fois à
stopper à stopper se financent à groix
réponse de les sanctions les sanctions
et certainement ces sanctions ils ont
déjà contribué à fragiliser de manière
spectaculaire la rouble s'est effondré
et on voit la pression auquel est soumis
le régime les entreprises d'état et les
oligarques qui touche qui se sont
directement dans dur du système vous
connaissez très sains et recteur adjoint
de la rédaction du figaro
c'est à vous bonsoir c'est un plaisir de
vous accueillir en france une première
question il ya un sondage qui est sorti
hier dans l'ifop dans le dans la presse
française dans des médias français
sondage réalisé par l'ifop et qui
apporte peut-être une bonne nouvelle
pour vous qui montre que 66% des
français se disent fiers voire très fier
d'être européen et un autre une autre
question à laquelle il répond dans dix
ans à 61% la france peut jouer un rôle
dans le monde mais si elle est dans le
cadre européen quelle est votre réaction
on fait plaisir je ne vais pas vous en
dire ça ça me fait plaisir c'est plutôt
c'est plutôt une heureuse surprise et ça
montre bien que quand on est confronté à
des crises et de l'adversité c'était le
cas avec le clovis et le cas aujourd'hui
tu l'aidés rend en ukraine on voit bien
que ce projet européen montre sa
puissance montrent son impact et ça me
fait plaisir que les citoyens en france
puissent mesurer l'impact c'est vous
dire une chose c'est que je suis très
convaincu dans cette crise duclos vie
qui nous a frappés ci avait pas eu
l'union européenne au moment où je vous
parle on serait dans des difficultés
encore bien plus inextricable je crois
que c'est cette ambition européenne
d'agir ensemble dont dans des sujets qui
sont en fait en principe déçu de
compétences nationales la santé prince
et à la compétence nationale quelque
chose malheur est bon alors mais en tout
cas en tout cas le projet européen à
chaque fois montré que quand il y avait
des crises bien souvent là cette
capacité de rebondir plus loin plus fort
et de faire des bonds des bons
intellectuelle des sursauts des sursauts
mentaux et de principes qui nous permet
effectivement de chaque édition vous
pensez que ce sentiment il est partagé
il est présent dans tous les pays
européens je le crois oui parce que même
les pays qui ont adhéré récemment oui je
leur centrale je le crois d'abord dans
un certain de sept de ces pays là il il
ya l'histoire que vous connaissez et
l'histoire en connexion avec la russie
c'est d'ailleurs pour cette pour ça que
dans ces pays là il ya cette grande
sensibilité à juste titre en lien avec
la situation à de la situation actuelle
une manière générale mon impression
c'est que à la fois la crise du coc vite
venir vient pas et cette guerre qui
s'est déclenché à montrer aux européens
qu'ils avaient une capacité de réaction
rapide qui a surpris poutine je n'y
reviens pas sur beaucoup de points mais
qui nous a surpris nous-mêmes je pense
qu'on nous sommes surpris nous mêmes par
à la fois l'impact nous pouvons avoir
cette capacité d'unité et de fermeté
c'est le retour du monde des empires je
ne le crois pas je crois qu'il ya eu la
tentation effectivement de la nostalgie
d el kala l'europe un empire jeunes que
cet ensemble de pays si ce n'est si ce
n'est que si ce n'est que là la grande
différence est que la tentation d empire
c'est toujours la tentation de
l'invasion nous ne sommes pas dans cette
démarche là en vain quant à sion de la
conviction la conviction sur les valeurs
qui nous rassemblent alors vous savez
qu'on est plein de paradoxes et les
français là le paradoxe français depuis
diderot on connaît c'est que 45% des
français dans ce même sondage disent à
l'europe oui mais l'europe des nations
ce qui est un peu différent de ce qui se
trame actuellement et le mot est pas
négatif dans ma bouche ce qui se fait
justement en mutualisant beaucoup
d'action que vous faites l'europe des
nations mais c'est sur base du
consentement sur base du consentement
démocratique puisque quand on décide
d'acheter des vaccins ensemble quand on
décide de faire un fonds de relance et
250 milliards d'euros on investit
ensemble et on va rembourser ensemble
pour le même objectif climat digital
quand on décide de livrer des armes à
l'ukraine parce que on voit bien que ce
sont nos valeurs qui sont mises en
danger quand on fait tout ça c'est le
consentement démocratique des chefs
d'état et de gouvernement qui engagent
leur démocratie nationale
cette formule l'unité dans la diversité
est plus que jamais elle et elle est
pertinente franck on doit respecter
évidemment les sensibilités les
préoccupations nationales
essentielles regardez le que vite hardy
on ne tremble pas on va de l'avant mais
les partisans de l'europe des nations si
vous me permettez précisément dénonce
l'efficacité de ce type d'achats groupés
en disant que ça aurait été beaucoup
plus efficace de le faire pays par pays
et que ça aurait été moins cher oui
enfin je pense ça résiste pas à 3 selon
deux à trois semaines a dit adan ali si
on est un peu c'est un peu un peu ce que
vous savez très bien si francs les
vaccins par exemple on sait très bien
que il y a tant de pays européens qui
aurait probablement pas de vaccin au
moment où on se parle c'est parce que
cette capacité de faire des achats
groupés pourquoi parce qu'ils auraient
une compétition avec une surenchère du
secteur pharmaceutique pour vendée axa à
ceux qui mettaient le plus de moyens sur
la table si on n'avait pas à mutualiser
les investissements dans la recherche
vaccinale le mourre n'aurait pas été
capable en moins d'un an de développer
un vaccin quand habituellement il faut
entre 8 et 10 ans pour développer un
vaccin dans ce genre de circonstances
alors ça vous a pas échappé des
élections en france dans quelques jours
maintenant dans 13 jours pour le premier
tour et si on regarde bien les
intentions de vote on s'aperçoit que
deux candidats précisément
nationaliste s'est pas toujours un gros
mot 1 mais on peut les appeler comme ça
et bien représentent 30% des intentions
de vote ce qui est énorme ce qui est
beaucoup plus que la gauche toutes
réunies et ce qui est presque plus aussi
que le président de la république
sortant
dont la cote
un petit peu baissé qu'est ce que ça
vous inspire cinq ans même avec des
termes pour l'un ou l'autre plutôt pour
l'un que pour l'une actuellement qui
sont parfois assez violent contre le
rendement je me réjouis que l'on tient
un débat dans un pays européens la
france en l'occurrence le débat sur
l'europe soyez de loeb est un des thèmes
de la campagne et c'est de plus en plus
vrai partout en europe ça c'est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle parce que parfois on
a le sentiment dans le passé tôt tenté
des campagnes nationales ont été
tournées citant une forme de repli
national moi je trouve qu'il est plutôt
bien que les électeurs en france
prochainement mais c'était le cas ce
week end à mal et des élections
quasiment en permanence sur le plan
européen quelque part en tout cas que
les électeurs aient l'occasion d'avoir
cessé cet échange démocratique cet
échange d'arguments comment veux tu
organises et l'interaction entre le
gouvernement national parlement national
d'un côté et puis les institutions
européennes moi je crois que si on est
authentiquement et sincèrement démocrate
on doit se réjouir à utiliser cette
vitalité là et puis au final ce sont les
électeurs et grand cerf les règles en
l'occurrence qui feront qui feront qui
font l'histoire des règlements au des
manuels ou depardon ou de marine le pen
ne vous fait pas peur ne fait pas
je suppose que vous vous pouvez imaginer
où se situe où se situe mais mes
impressions sur ce qui est nécessaire
pour l'avenir de l'europe vient de
parler pendant pratiquement au diner de
cette ambition de donner plus de force
et ce projet à ce projet opéra mais je
n'ai pas non plus l'intention de venir
dans le débat alors juste d'avancer si
vous me permettez un petit droit de
suite vous avez parlé tout à l'heure de
la défense européenne et je trouve que
j'ai bougrement compliqué et que la
réalité est en train d'infirmer
peut-être ce qui est dit ici ou là on
dit la france l'europe ça y est ça lui a
donné un coup de fouet cette guerre en
ukraine et va essayer de et bien
mutualiser son effort de guerre et elle
va réussir ce qu'on n'a jamais réussi
finalement à faire une défense
européenne mais je trouve que c'est pas
vrai du tout puisque en fait ça a
réactivé l'organisation du traité de
l'atlantique-nord l'otan qui était
paraît-il dans une mort cérébrale n'y a
pas très longtemps et que finalement les
pays d'europe centrale notamment eux ils
sont il se moque un peu de l'europe de
la défense ils veulent être sous le
parapluie américain parce qu'ils savent
que l'amérique c'est du solide donc
c'est bien difficile non ya pas une
contradiction là le choix finalement
c'est l'échec de l'europe de la défense
une nouvelle fois parce que les pays
vont se mettre sous bannière américaine
mais on peut vous êtes parfaitement dans
votre rôle vous félicite pas si vous le
faites vous le faites diablement bien
fait diablement bien mais ça ne
correspond pas à la réalité est faite il
ya un décalage entre l'impression que
vous avez hélas la réalité de la
dynamite au sein du conseil européen
vous avez raison je suis à quelques mois
encore quand dans dans mes conversations
intimes avaient des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement venant du flanc est de
l'union européenne y avait certainement
une forme de doute quant au caractère
sérieux de cette ambition pour l'heure
de la défense manière plus générale il
va doutes sur cette ambition portée avec
par le plan macro et avait d'autres j'en
suis pour la gêne pas de souveraineté
européen et maintenant on voit que en
peu de temps réalité il ya une
transformation mentale une
transformation intellectuelle
transformation des esprits il tombe dans
cette part de danse est par là de
l'europe est là où vous avez raison
autrefois cpi peut être voyez l'europe
mettant le projet de soutien économique
de soutien de prospérité et le temps le
projet pour la sécurité je vois qu'il ya
une compréhension maintenant qui est
unanime je vous invite à lire
attentivement cette boussole stratégique
qui est vraiment un moment de
transformation
copernicien ou plus pernicieuse ballon
il faut le dire de ce projet européen en
matière de défense maintenant je
comprends que l'on nous dise attendons
de voir ça je comprends qu'il puisse y
avoir cette prudence là mais nous
appartiendra à notre série de mettre en
oeuvre et je vous donne rendez vous si
vous m'invitez encore dans six mois dans
un an dans deux ans et vous verrez je le
crois qu'en la situation aujourd'hui est
la situation que vous observerez il y
aura des évolutions tangible alors
demain dans le figaro joule annonce
un entretien il rencontre avec monsieur
khodorkovski qui est un des oligarques
quelques problèmes c'est peu de le dire
avec le président poutine et qui dit en
fait l'ambition de poutine de vladimir
poutine s'est pas tellement l'ukraine
d'absorber ukraine c'est et bien de se
confronter et de se confronter aux états
unis et à l'otan je le crois aussi je
prends le croyait aussi pourquoi pas
reculer parce que le temps comme l'union
européenne ou portant des valeurs de
démocratie et je pense je le dire encore
que l'agneau foot est en quelques sortes
voix voile démocratie qu une pandémie
dont il a peur et voilà dire comme un
vaccin
la guerre toutes ses formes d'ailleurs
parce que eux aussi on ne sommes
confrontés aujourd'hui à une guerre
traditionnelle la totale brutalité de la
lyre traditionnel mais ce sont des
généraux russes qui ont inventé la
doctrine de la guerre hybride qui plonge
eu des actes de malveillance de
déstabilisation cyberattaques lé
propagande corruption pour tenter de
fragiliser ce qu'ils perçoivent comme
étant des adversaires parce que
fondamentalement ce qu'il veut c'est
démontrer que le modèle démocratique ne
fonctionne pas 2 on a été confronté sa
audio date risque évident lorsque des
autocrates tenter lorsque ont balbutié
un peu dans les premiers jours il faut
le reconnaître on a mis quelques jours
et quelques semaines avant de se mettre
en ordre de marche sur le sujet on est
et on compte assez de propagande et est
la situation aujourd'hui ce sont les
modèles démocratiques qui s'en sortent
bien mieux que ce qu'ils aient quelques
temps nous faisait la leçon et eux sont
en difficulté toute petite question et
vous m'avez tendu la perche d'une
certaine façon parce qu'on n'a pas du
tout parlé c'est tout le set univers
cyber chacun et d'aucuns disent même que
c'est peut-être la prochaine crise après
la crise sanitaire c'est cette crise
cyber rideau tous les systèmes à plat
est ce que l'europe qui n'a pas créé les
gaffes et qui n'a pas créé de gaf 1 dans
ce domaine et peut avoir une capacité de
réplique ok on est on est on est y
travaillant on extrêmement conscient et
ne découvre pas ça aujourd'hui c'est
plus roanne et il en a bien compris
qu'il y avait une faiblesse structurelle
qu'il fallait corriger dans dans
l'urgence absolue c'est ainsi que l'on
travaille notamment dans cette boussole
stratégie pour mettre en commun des
capacités de résistance des capacités de
réaction il faut non pas il faut pas non
plus être dans la bordant dans
l'inquiétude totale parce que nous avons
des capacités or c'est vrai que certains
pays europe ont développé plus que
d'autres mais encore une fois on le voit
bien sur une crise cyber aucun de nos
états membres fut-il le plus puissant
seule ne pourra résister et de poura ne
pourra retourner la situation en sa
faveur c'est bien la coopération qui
sera qui sera absolument fondamental
pour pouvoir surmonter ce type de
situation certains se disent depuis le
début de la guerre la seule solution
c'est que poutine soit renversée de
l'intérieur sinon il ira le plus loin
possible et peut-être au-delà de ce
qu'on peut imaginer est ce que c'est
votre avis j'ai pas je vais pas pu
partager un sentiment avec vous moi je
trois jeunes eux ceux qui pensent que
lorsque l'admirent poutine a appuyé le
boute sur le bouton je déclenche la
guerre et j'envoie 160 ici dès le
premier jour peut-être at-il sans le
savoir sans le mesurer appuie aussi sur
le bouton auto destruction de son propre
régime mais je suis réaliste ça peut
prendre du temps on a vu dans le passé
notamment en russie il peut être très
dangereux s'il se sent acculé c'est pour
ça que la situation est extrêmement
sérieuse et en tout cas c'est le peuple
russe qui aura de mon point de vue en
tout cas la réponse était de dire telle
qu'elle est quel est le gouvernement
qu'il souhaite merci beaucoup charles
michel était notre invité aujourd'hui
vous allez retourner à bruxelles imagine
après cette émission c'était très clair
merci à vous merci yves thréard on serre
s'ils avaient évidemment la semaine
prochaine sur la chaîne parlementaire
pour un prochain numéro de 10 ans public
notre invité sera laurent berger le
patron de la cfdt bonne soirée sur la
chaîne parlementaire
[Musique]